um welcome everyone
to the uh
weekly d mice thursday
informatics conference which we plan to
continue in the new academic year even
though
our um format is different with this
virtual format
um but we still plan to hold the
conference
and record them and post them on our
youtube channel
um and so um the
this is the first week of the new
academic quarter so this is the first uh
conference
of the academic year and um
just a reminder that next week mostly
reminder to faculty and students that
next week is our annual open house which
of course will be
conducted virtually there will be
and actually embedded within it is next
week's conference of which i will give
my annual state of the program
overview there's also
student panels and other kinds of
activities posters and so forth and so
hopefully
faculty and students will participate so
the topic of today's conference is
telemedicine
this is an area that has been impacted
profoundly by the
covet 19 pandemic this department has
some history
in telemedicine doing systematic reviews
through the evidence-based practice
center
of what used to be a very kind of niche
technology used very minimally
not getting reimbursed so not having
impact that way
and then things literally changed
overnight with the onset of the pandemic
and
the shutting down of the health system
and the economy and so forth um and so
what we're going to hear today is a
presentation
of what happened here at ohsu
which for the involved speakers was
quite uh substantial and
there were already plans for moving
towards virtual visits
and so forth and um this just pushed
things along
so we have three speakers today they
actually all sent me really nice bios
but unfortunately i'm not going to be
able to
cover everything in them the one thing
so the speakers as listed on the slides
are miles l b
uh steve kasaki and darren malinowski
can actually say that between myself and
two of the speakers we have three
of the five medical schools in chicago
covered
um i'll get to that in a moment we also
have both baseball teams
both of which are in the playoffs now um
anyways but let me give brief
introductions because i don't want to
take up
too much of their time um so um
uh dr miles l b is a
um hang on one sec um
is a professor of pediatrics
uh he is a pediatrician he's also headed
um telemedicine programs at ohsu
as long as he's been here and
he is also medical director of ohsu's
office of digital health
he has a long background of
telemedicine projects both in the state
of oregon and also
beyond including internationally he um
actually did undergraduate at university
of illinois which is where i did my
undergraduate as well
i think i have a few years on him and
then he um went to medical school at
university of chicago
i actually continued on at university of
illinois so we have
that's two of the three chicago schools
covered
the second speaker listed is dr kasaki
in the odd man
out in terms of chicago medical schools
he did his medical training and training
in internal medicine at brown
university he then actually joined our
national library of medicine
informatics fellowship this was before
the subspecialty existed
and he's also trained in internal
medicine
after completing the fellowship he
stayed on his faculty so he's an
assistant professor in d
mice he's also been for several years
now the associate chief health
information officer
and has a major um operational role at
ohsu and then the third speaker dr
darren malinowski let me just get my
cheat sheet here
is ohsu's chief clinical transformation
officer
um trained as a surgeon and is a
professor of surgery in the division of
trauma and surgical critical care
here at ohsu so he splits his time
between being a surgeon and then also
being involved in a number of leadership
roles
um including being involved now with the
office of digital health he went to
medical school at northwestern
university the
third chicago area medical school and
also has done a lot of research over the
years has over
100 peer-reviewed publications
in organ donor management traumatic
injuries and
prevention of complications in surgical
icus but they have all come together
and been involved in rolling out and
basically moving
ohsu forward um into the
um telemedicine telehealth uh arena
oh and then i was i said i was gonna
mention baseball um
dr ellenby uh uh notes that he's a big
chicago white sox fan i'm more
more of a north side or so a chicago
cubs fan both
of whom are in the baseball playoffs but
we're here to talk about telemedicine
so i'm going to turn it over to three of
them and then i'll let them
carry things out with the slides and and
so forth and hopefully we'll have a
little bit
um of um uh time for some uh
question and answer and i i see that dr
malinowski is a cubs fan so
so we out outnumber the white sox fans
but
anyways go ahead guys
uh thanks bill um
well even though we don't share a team
we've all shared the suffering of
chicago sports fandom so
that we do i'll carry together um well
thank you for uh giving us this
opportunity to speak with you all about
uh telehealth
uh i was asked to uh cover our kind of
our past history and how we got in this
business in the first place
and then steve and darren will follow
with uh
what happened with kovid and where we
are moving uh forward
um so what i'd like to start off
by saying is that telehealth is not
exactly a new idea
uh in fact this is a cover from a 1925
magazine called science and invention uh
featuring what was called the teledactyl
uh the this was a vision of uh inventor
and writer hugo gernsbach
a name that you guys might know from the
world science fiction awards
uh the hugos and he was fairly president
in this concept
um and if you look at this device it
looks a little bit like the da vinci
robotic
surgical platform um so uh he said
at that time uh as our civilization
progresses we find it more and more
necessary to act at a distance
i don't think he thought about kovid in
this relation but
um he then went on that the busy doctor
50 years hence will not be able to visit
his patients as he does now
it takes too much time and he can only
at best see a limited number today
whereas the services of a really big
doctor are so important that he could
never
have to leave his office on the other
hand his patients cannot always come to
see him
this is where the teledactyl and
diagnosis by radio comes in
so not a new concept um
formally defined telehealth is
interactive healthcare over distance
using telecommunication technology and
for decades
there's been a lot of uh utilization and
kind of the
what i would say is not as exciting but
the more mundane storm ford
version centered around radiographic
imaging and interpretations of studies
in an asynchronous method
a lot of what we're going to be focusing
on today is the concept of face-to-face
interactive interactions with our
patients support providers
as well as the concept of remote patient
monitoring
and as you should know if if you can
think about a
utilization people are trying it one of
the big questions
for the researchers out there is whether
it's
safe care if it improves outcomes and if
it's efficient for providers
so again people have tried things on the
inpatient outpatient side both
synchronously and asynchronously
and uh there's some pretty creative
utilization out there again
big question is is it is a good cure
we first got involved with this uh uh
13 14 almost 15 years ago now
and our motivation centered out of my
group in pediatric intensive care with
the recognition
that folks in general really want
specialty services everywhere and at all
times regardless of the geography of
where they live
but we also know that that's not always
possible
and again pediatric critical care uh one
of the realities that we've known uh
this is an
iom study from 2006 is that while
children make up more than a quarter of
all emergency room visits
only six percent of those ers
said that they had the necessary
supplies and expertise to take care of
those children
and then another reality that we know is
that regionalization of services to
centers of excellence improves outcomes
and there are studies like this across
the spectrum of healthcare
from a variety of different fields but
not every
hospital can have a pediatric icu or a
transplant center and so on and so forth
so how do we match that desire in that
reality
and then to look at it more specifically
around the area of
pediatric intensive care and our region
in oregon there are only three pediatric
icus in the entire state
and they're all here in portland very
closely located
and if you need a pediatric icu farther
away you have to go up to seattle tacoma
down to the south to the bay area
sacramento and out east towards spokane
and boise so it's a very large catchment
area
and what we have known over the decades
uh is that we have transport
a lot of children up to portland for
higher levels of care
we transport more than a thousand kids a
year um and
rambled us a similar level of activity
and that's a lot of movement
one of the things we've also known is
that a lot of those children were
transplanted unnecessarily
sometimes at great risk because medical
transport's a dangerous business and of
course
it's expensive and on the other end of
the spectrum we found a number of
children were inadequately resuscitated
as well and we feel a lot of that
issue the poor triage decisions about
who to transport who's not is from a
poor exchange of data
over a telephone um
and so what this plays out day by day is
that we get console calls all the time
from around the state and the dilemma
that we face
on the phone is whether or not to
transport that child
and in the old way of doing business
that was based on a verbal report
from the local provider who is often an
adult trained
er doc or a pediatrician without any
critical care training
and you can often hear in their voice
their own comfort and their
their stress level of dealing with a
sick child
and in that short brief phone call with
a limited data exchange
we are they're making this big decision
and then there's all these other layers
of comfort that go into this whether the
institution is comfortable
caring for that child that provider and
as well as the parents some parents want
to come at the drop of the hat and
others
are very resistant to being transported
um and obviously this is a huge decision
uh obviously it impacts the child
i do think we often forget as providers
what we do to families and the parents
when we bring people up here
unnecessarily
take them away from their other support
systems the ability to care for their
other children
continue to work and so forth and again
given that
medical transport is dangerous sometimes
we put our team at risk
the last thing i want to do in the
middle of the winter when the when i'm
hearing from the
dispatch that maybe we can get the plane
in i really want to know that we
need to go um and then finally it's
expensive
uh panda's our dedicated pediatric team
and when we go back ground
it's uh nine thousand dollars in a
ground transport
and when we go by fixed wing plane it's
more than 24 grand and that's just for
the medical transport
there are other significant financial
impacts as well
to the local health care system that
likes to maintain their patients if
possible
as well as the family and the local
economy
so is there a way to do this better well
this is a catchphrase i've developed
over the years but
we all know a phone call can be helpful
and a picture's worth a thousand words
but
live interactive video is really
priceless apologies to mastercard
the difference between hearing that the
baby's breathing fast and where he's
going to try her out
and i'm anxious you can hear it in my
voice versus me actually being able to
see that
interact with the patient and the family
makes all the difference in the world
does take a little bit longer but it
takes what can often be a very short
quick anonymous phone call with poor
data exchange to a very much more
intimate
interaction over video so
we were able to start a pilot with
sacred heart and eugene in 2007
with the goal of as i said reducing
unnecessary transports
as well as supporting resuscitation and
we were able to show over the first two
and a half years of that program that we
saw 80 children there
a full third of them were able to stay
locally now some of that might have
happened over the phone but i can tell
you there's a number of circumstances
whereas the video
that provided that comfort and then on
the other end of the spectrum we
supported them with some
uh some resuscitations and i can tell
you some pretty harrowing stories but
the ability to see what's going on and
see what the patient's response to the
internet to the interventions
really could make all the difference we
were able to convince the
organization that this was not just a
one-off neat little project but this is
actually a way of delivering
care so in 2010 we expanded
as a network around the state to 16
hospitals
and the services offered included picu
adult stroke coverage which both locally
and around the country has been the
biggest utilizer of acute
telemedicine there are a lot of stroke
mimics there's a lot of er doctors that
are very hesitant to give tpa
our neurologists are able to join those
teams in real time
our neonatologists have supported some
pretty uh
dramatic newborn resuscitations and we
are now on the adult side developing a
tele icu program
which over the past year uh is now being
morphed into a
instead of a reactive model a proactive
virtual icu model
in partnership with ge we're developing
a platform to do that work and this will
be launched very soon
so what we've been able to do over this
roughly decade is
take care and be part of the care of
more than 3000 oregonians
um in those 16 hospitals and to be
honest we've really stopped counting but
we've
estimated that we've saved many millions
of dollars and avoided transport costs
many of those patients are able to stay
locally in their community
by by improving the comfort level of the
local providers
that's of course going to vary by
service line adult versus pediatric
and with specific service lines and the
comfort of that community hospital
some hospitals have more capability than
others the other important
thing that allows us to do is to build
and maintain relationships with these
referring centers because we all know
how important it is that they
they send us patients and that's an
important part to this as well
um finally this is just a visual on what
the developing
ge mural platform is going to look like
it's for our virtual icu which is again
the proactive model where we're going to
be monitoring
a number of icus uh with a nurse and a
physician
to provide nighttime coverage to a
number of centers around the state that
just
there are not enough intensivists to to
care for patients 24 7.
um so in addition
to uh growing that acute care network
over this past decade we also recognize
the opportunity
to to deploy telehealth solutions across
the care continuum
and have had have had small growing
platforms in all these area
areas a good way to break these up is to
group them into who's connecting to who
either the provider to the patient
directly or whether it's provider to
provider
as well as whether the communication is
synchronous or asynchronous
and again these are uh deployed both in
the ambulatory and inpatient setting
uh and this list calls out a number of
the different offerings that we've
developed
over the years and uh they will be
touched on further in the subsequent
parts of this talk
one area we're not going to talk about
very much more is the concept of remote
patient monitoring
but this is an idea where those with
chronic disease or recently discharged
can now deploy a connected device
in their home where they upload daily
physiologic data to their care team to
help with their management
we've had some initial success in this
area um but more researchers definitely
needed to
to see if this intensive monitoring both
improves outcomes
saves money and also saves
um to note in 2019 of the roughly
million ambulatory encounters
a very small number of those were
performed over digital platforms but
as steve is about to tell you that all
changed
i'll hand it over to you great thanks so
much miles um
so i'm steve casakin i know many of the
people on on the
call so i have the good fortune to sort
of share
the story and our experience um during
covet and so i think there's a lot of
ways
and probably a lot of cliches that can
be used for sort of what happened right
this sort of earthquake
parted the river um and we'll go into
some of that
um i think about this is really when
telemedicine sort of really arrived i
think prior to
um covid telemedicine was was something
that
had opportunity had promise and was
seeing some some success in sort of very
specific areas
but really wasn't accepted in in a
widespread fashion
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
sort of walk through um kind of what was
going on with
with telemedicine specifically focus
focusing on outpatient
and video visits what was sort of
missing pre-covid how kovitz served as a
catalyst
our experience at ohsu and how we scaled
it and then talk about some of the
challenges and opportunities
um the figure that i'm sharing on the
first slide is actually just a
um a timeline so on the y-axis you can
see that's the total number of visits
and then the timeline is from january
um through to the end of august and the
gray color represents our in-person
visits
um so if you go to january 2020 you can
see that
almost everything we were doing was in
person there is a
little slice of telephone visits i think
that's orange i'm colorblind
and the other one is a faint line maybe
you can make out there blue for video
but there really wasn't much activity
and as you can see that that really
changed um starting in in march so we'll
sort of talk about that
you can go the next slide miles
so the way i think about um video visits
in the sort of
pre-covet state i think the first place
that we saw a lot of use was in
urgent care and i call it the urgent
care extravaganza you can go online and
and almost every institution and many
sort of private vendors and
and some pop you know some some public
companies were offering an urgent care
solution and the idea was
you know really born out of convenience
there um so you need to see a doctor you
can get on and see one but the
scope of practice around it was pretty
limited the idea was
we'll focus on really kind of low acuity
things things that probably don't need
labs maybe don't need you know
prescriptions in limited cases
um whether it's successful i'm i'm not
really sure i think it really was pretty
pretty limited for my from my sense we
had employed one of these like many
institutions we
have a group of um advanced practice
providers that are located in our
emergency room and we've had this
program for probably about 18 months
and they fill all their sessions um i
think it's a valuable service but it
really wasn't mainstream
um and one of the big challenges that i
think it saw is there's a lot
of decent evidence out there that
actually patients really want to see
and be seen by an established provider
so they would prefer to see
their own primary care doctor first if
not their own primary care doctor
they'd prefer to see someone else in the
practice and then the the person they
sort of rank as
least interested in in seeing is someone
they've never seen before at an
organization
they've sort of never had care with um
the other challenges
the financial no if you go back one just
real quick miles
the other challenge here is the
financial and regulatory state of this
was really complicated
so basically people took the approach
for the most part that for the urgent
care stuff it was going to be kind of a
cash pay approach
it was too complicated to build medicare
many private insurers didn't cover it
well or completely
some states required it some states and
so it's very confusing so most people
just said
we're going to charge cash and i think
for the you know the big problems facing
the healthcare organization
this kind of solution was never really
going to have much of an impact because
of its
sort of targeted approach next slide
please miles
so the next thing that i think most a
lot of people went after was well what
if we sort of
move away from just the urgent care
model and sort of this kind of low
acuity acute conditions
and what if we try to see you know can
we apply this in primary care and
specialty care
and i think there was a lot of interest
in doing that and a lot of excitement
and a lot of people sort of built out
systems to do this
we did as well one of the things that we
heard from a lot of people
when i had conversations with folks
before we actually implemented this they
said
yeah you know we've gone through we've
done it we've educated everybody we've
pushed it out to our patients we've done
a lot of marketing about it
people are excited about it but we just
don't see the uptake right so kind of
the the field of dreams concept
and i apologize i've got some animations
in this miles that you're unfortunately
going to be
tapping on so you can just tap through
the rest of it um
and really i think that the challenges
there were that the provider acceptance
was minimal we did have areas and other
people did
with kind of very excited providers who
were very motivated who really worked
hard who had
kind of good use cases for their
patients so we are at geographically
um you know geographically we have a
wide geographic catchment area so we do
have patients that are coming
you know for a routine visit from three
or four hundred miles away so
some of those patients and use cases
really took off
but on the whole what we saw was within
a clinic some providers were doing it
you know a day every other week and it
was really kind of minimal
and then even the patients it wasn't as
if there were people were screaming for
it
um the other challenge again was the
regulations became
i think even more of a problem because
in this model it's
with your primary care it's with your
specialty care you can't really do a
cash pay model in that case but the
insurance
stuff was still very complicated so
medicare
as will be kind of something we talk
about a little bit more too
was just very confusing to understand
who you could do it with where that
patient had to be located
and so most people just kind of threw up
their head and said you just can't do
this with medicare patients it's
it's too confusing and so i think it was
because of those constraints
really hard um and so something that
just really didn't
didn't catch on in the in the
pre-coveted state we go the next slide
miles
so covet came out right and i think
covet is the to a large degree for
telemedicine especially for videos was
the proverbial burning platform
so we saw in the in the early weeks of
march we saw the in the in-person visits
in the ambulatory setting start to drop
off right so people were hearing on the
news about povid really before the state
was clear about what exactly we were
going to do before the institution was
exactly clear
um and so we do about 3 000 visits a day
in ambulatory sort of averaged over the
week um
and as you can see in the in the early
part of the week of 318 the visits
started
dropping off precipitously and then on
march 16th there was a directive that
came out from ohsu basically
we're going to cancel all the clinics
and the only people who should be seen
are those who need to be seen
urgently and be seen in person um
so prior to this happening you know we
started getting
we started sort of hearing what was
going on the informatics group and the
tell health group were involved in a lot
of the coveted stuff
one of the interesting things for me
about this there never really was a
formal request from leadership no one
sort of came to us and said we need to
do this
it just became so obvious because all
these people who in the past we had to
cajole
convince twist arms say hey you should
really try telemedicine it's interesting
you know let us come talk about it this
kind of thing all of a sudden they were
beating down the gates and said when can
we get on when can we get on
um so it was pretty clear there was a
huge need in that and that
we needed to do something about it and
go the next slide miles
so when we did this process in the
pre-state
we had about 15 video visits a day
and over the course of three weeks we
took that to 900 a day
we had about 50 users for video visits
in the ambulatory setting
and that went to 1200 over three weeks
so an enormous scale
um when i think back and talk with the
team members about sort of what was what
was really helpful for this there's kind
of a few key things i want to sort of
hit on
so one was leadership endorsement as i
mentioned before we never really got
asked to do this but the need was
completely obvious
but we needed to make sure that this
sort of dedication of these resources
was going to be
supported by leadership and then also
the process that we were going to do
it was clear you know we couldn't do
everybody at once right so we had to
sort of think about how to do that
um we eventually sort of put that work
together took it to leadership and said
this is what we'd like to do we'd like
your endorsement and we got a resounding
yes which was
very helpful then in terms of organizing
the team so i think for those of you
that don't
um you know have a lot of operational
experience the the complexity of sort of
managing a complex application like epic
is is really
really hard um the epic sort of forces
you to basically break up all your teams
into sort of
these little sort of knowledge sets this
person knows everything about this
extremely small bit of application but
when you think about the care the care
pathway you know care is going to touch
on all these different applications it's
going to touch on
registration it's going to touch on
scheduling it's going to touch on the
clinical application
it's going to touch on the networking
piece with the external video vendor
it's going to touch on billing and so
you need to pull all these people
together
traditionally this work is very slow we
kind of take a waterfall approach to
this
um but we weren't going to be able to do
that so we really need to get things
organized
and then we needed to prioritize it
right as i said everybody wanted it and
everybody wanted it now
we weren't going to be able to deliver
that and we needed to sort of have a
clear prioritization which which we came
up with
and then we needed to basically
streamline the process and then just
kind of keep repeating this process over
and over
um as i'll talk about a little bit more
so you can go the next slide miles
so for our team organization we actually
ended up um
creating what we called uh tiger teams
so we had some
mama tiger team across all of um all of
the healthcare i.t
that basically sort of provided
oversight over all the baby tiger teams
that we formed the first
baby tiger team um for this process we
had members from nine different
departments
um as i said before epic is very complex
and you also need people from compliance
and legal and billing
um to be able to do that so we had nine
different people one of the things we
identified
early is that we needed these resources
these people 100
dedicated um so we basically said is
there anything else
that anyone in this group is working on
if so let us know and we're going to
have it
you know transferred over to someone
else we'll let your manager or director
know because we need you basically
working on this 100 um the other thing
that was really important in in terms of
basically letting them stay focused was
there was an ask on maybe the second or
third day from the teams can we stop
responding to other people about other
things because we're still getting you
know all these requests to just turn us
on
turn on the video or do this other
project and work on that and we
basically said for this group we're
going to say
you don't have to respond to emails or
phone calls or skype messages
for anything else other than this
project and we'll sort of provide the
support to be able to do that
it was pretty clear that this this was
you know highly complex work with a lot
of visibility and something we needed to
deliver
quickly um so we basically had the teams
work around the clock so we had meetings
and worked seven days a week for about
three weeks so the um one of the people
you know in the first week we log all of
our hours put in 80 plus hours on this
project so really
really enormous amount of effort um one
of the things we also realized when we
when we wanted to
to do this work was we need to leverage
kind of existing vendors and solutions
we didn't think we would be able to do
this
if we had to go through kind of
contracting or any
even talking with a vendor in that
process so we wanted to try to use
everything we had and we needed it to
happen quickly
and so one of the things we also did is
you know we knew we needed to sort of
prioritize the work for how we were
going to get the video out
but we realized that we could probably
get out the telephone stuff because it
already existed
we could get that out the door in two
days and basically give everybody
something to kind of keep them
i'll say sort of satisfied for a couple
of weeks
and so when you have the telephone
really what that allows you to do is
allows you to schedule patients
it allows you to document on the
patients and it allows you to do your
your billing and revenue cycle and then
keep all that in the ehr so we basically
push that out the door within two days
just say okay everyone has telephone
visits and now we're going to sort of
set the timeline and deliver on the
video
in total this three-week effort alone
took us was 1500 hours from all the
resources
um so a real substantial amount of work
miles you can go to the next slide
the other thing um that was really
important in the process was basically
going through what our process was right
so how are we actually going to do this
there's a technology piece but then
there's sort of the administrative
onboarding
so really at the first meeting one of
the things we surfaced we said
just let's define what the current state
of this process is right now
um and the document you see on the page
sort of speaks to that there's
there's three other steps that i cut off
just because i didn't want to show it
over two pages
but this process um as if you look
actually in the first box which is
really
user requests it and and we set an
expectation at the top that it may take
three months
right that's our goal okay so right away
that process is not gonna
this is not gonna work so we literally
went through all these processes kind of
line by line and said
we want everything to go um
because the process you know if we're
gonna do this we basically need to just
push this out you can tap there's
another
animation coming in there miles so
really remove it remove every step and
have no user involvement
so i'm just going to kind of use this a
little bit to sort of walk through some
of the things we did
um so we realized this didn't need to be
a poll right we didn't need users saying
oh i want to do it we understood that
everybody needed it
so we basically just said okay we're
going to take all the groups that we
think
should go in wave one wave two wave
three we're gonna sort of have
conversations with some clinical leaders
seek the endorsement and then basically
say this is the this is the phasing of
this process
so no one has to request it and we did
that pretty early on
in an institution there are things for
the providers called privileges which
basically
are kind of a medical legal activity
which sort of defines what care you can
and can't do
um you do at our institution have to
have telemedicine privileges
in the past the providers had to request
them so we went to the medical staff
office and said we would like everybody
privileged
for telemedicine we want people to go
through this process and and that was a
little bit hard for them because usually
privileging
you know they have a very specific
process they meet monthly they look at
the names they like to go through it but
that really wasn't going to work for us
so we were able to get that
um and then the next step we could skip
down to sort of
step six so prior to this we basically
the training model was
okay providers department says they want
to do it we have a bunch of meetings we
get them set up
then the providers have to do a compass
module which was an is it kind of our
online test
our online education platform they would
do that for about
i think was an hour and a half then they
would take a test then they would
schedule a time to sit with one of the
people from telemedicine the educator
do a skills assessment that and then
they would do that with kind of a test
patient and then they would have their
first two
video visits um chaperone essentially to
sort of watch that activity
and so we basically looked at this and
we just took a big red pen and said
that's not that's not going to work
so what we're going to do is we're going
to cut down the training substantially
with the idea that most people are going
to get it
most people are going to be able to
figure it out so there's a five-minute
training we're going to
take it on the honor system that you're
going to do it no test and then what we
also do is
there are going to be people who are
going to struggle we're gonna have you
know hundreds or you know
thousand new people using this so we
need to have more support so we actually
took all the scribes
who were previously scribing physically
in the clinic and we reassign them to
the help desk to be able to support
the questions from both the providers
and the patients and that was really
helpful
um the other thing that we did was we
changed the
the platform model so previously to do
this work you had to do it on an
ohsu-owned machine and that machine had
to have a specific
local epic client um our departments
don't provide
all the clinicians their own laptops so
that clearly wasn't going to work
so we basically flipped the model and we
said look we think everybody's got a
smartphone and
haiku epic's mobile application is both
android
and iphone available so we're going to
use that
so you everyone is going to go on your
iphone or your android you're going to
get the video
and audio through that and then you can
document on whatever
you have at home because you can remote
in through that or you could do it in
the clinic
and that basically cut out any of the um
you know any of the device issues
because we basically said we're going to
do a bring your own device
thing and everybody had them already so
you can go to the next slide miles
um so one of the things that um
is also really important to think about
is we basically
i'm sort of focusing on the for the
three weeks which is really focused on
bringing all the faculty live
um but we basically have done the entire
house so as of two days ago we basically
disbanded the video visit team
but they have enabled every single
clinician at ohsu
who is a scheduled person which is kind
of how we think about who needs it
and we've also done all the trainees so
all the house staff and fellows
um or and then all the students so np pa
the dietitian all the students that are
out there the rn students so it's really
kind of
very uniform now um one of the things
that's interesting to
sort of see is you know there's still
quite a bit of telephone usage
um and i think there's gonna be some
interesting things to think about that i
have a couple things to say in uh
the next slide or so miles
so one of the one of the important
things to understand is kind of the
backdrop
backdrop of sort of what allowed this to
happen so um
as i said before one of the reasons
telemedicine didn't sort of
really take off before is there was a
lot of complication a lot of
restrictions
so when covet happened there was a
public health emergency declared so
that's a formal sort of federal
declaration
and then the health and human services
was able to move forward with something
called the 1135
waiver which you could think of one
politician told me you could think of it
as basically it's just
you can basically clear out all the
regulatory underbrush
um with this and that's what they did so
things that happened so the office of
civil rights basically came out and said
we're not going to enforce anything
related to hipaa on any video platform
you're using so
we didn't decide to do this our
institution but other people you know
they use
they use facetime they use facebook
messenger it was kind of a free-for-all
you could use whatever you want
one of the critical things was the
loosening of the regulations with
medicare so
home you couldn't you weren't allowed to
see a patient at home it's kind of
strange but you the patient physically
wasn't allowed to be
located home they had to be located at
specific specified original sites the
patient had to also be in a specific
geographic area
um medicare basically got rid of that
temporarily
they also made eligible providers
expanded the type of services
allowed audio only which wasn't
previously allowed and they came forward
with payment parity
um so video visits audio only visits
they're going to go at the same rate as
the office visits
private payers had less regulation and
basically followed suit with medicare
and then the states um provided leniency
on interstate licensing so
for me to practice i can video into
someone in oklahoma
but the state of oklahoma has authority
over what i can do there so i
technically have
to have a license there to do it there
was a lot of relaxation
with that as well um and then also the
medic medicaid is administered at the
state level
lots of relaxation there as well miles
we can go to the next slide
um one of the big things though that's i
think come out of this is telemedicine
is sort of you know was in this sort of
slow adoption state where we had a lot
of time to think about its effect and
people were able to study it in specific
populations
um it's really now mainstream right so i
think the idea that
telemedicine maybe is even a thing it's
maybe just it's part of medicine the way
we do business
really brings out sort of you know how
the need to really think critically
about what
effect it's going to have on health care
particularly i think with the
disparities so
disparities are pervasive in in medicine
that's been known for a long time i
think that's come much more into the
public
um sphere with covid i think a lot of
people
are are who didn't sort of think about
these issues maybe on a policy level are
much more aware of them now
but there's a lot of concern from from a
lot of different stakeholders in the
system about
what will happen when we now that we've
mainstream telemedicine so one of the
you know
i think remarkable statistics that you
look at is basically a quarter of the
medicare patients don't have
the equipment to be able to do it so
what happens to those people
um you know our health care system in
its fee-for-service model has very
strange
ways in which it will respond to
incentives um the other concern is how
is removing some of the emergency
provisions going to affect disparities
so this is actually
um some work that one of the informatics
fellows jonathan sachs is working with
me on and basically looking at
are there different uh modalities that
different patients patient populations
are using
and if people are using for instance
audio only more and that's a limitation
at the patient end what happens if we
stop paying for audio
basically there's a potential that you
sort of further disadvantage those
those patients so a lot of things to
think about there
and then um you know in terms of
thinking about
the you know the disparities and what
will happen with the policies
when the when the public health
emergency is over
the 1135 waiver basically just
disappears and so there's a lot of
regulatory and statutory changes people
are looking to
to kind of put into place to do that um
but there's a lot of work to be done so
we've had the good fortune
um to work actually with senator wyden
and his staff on some of the
some of the things that we think are
really critical to sort of go forward
because some of these things do actually
have to be changed in law
not just in the regulations so this is
just a
screenshot of the text of the bill that
that has been introduced in the senate
that
we're hopeful we'll move forward so i
think that's
it for my slide so i'm going to hand it
over to
me again miles yeah so i'm just going to
very quickly in the interest time cover
uh some inpatient that work work that we
did around covet as well
and uh it should be pretty obvious now
why we were motivated to
to make some changes on the inpatient
side primarily are focused around
protecting our providers and patients by
reducing unnecessary exposures and to
preserve ppe
there's also the concern that some
providers might be in quarantine
still able to practice but not able to
come to the hospital can we add them to
our care team
and also to improve communication
between the patient and the primary team
for patients in isolation
again without increasing their exposure
risk
additional opportunities uh came up that
weren't uh specifically covert related
and these focused on
uh telephone interprofessional consults
uh what we
have finally called curbsides where a
provider will communicate with another
provider to get a recommendation but not
directly involve the patient
uh this work is not reimbursable as well
as using
our video uh platform in the hospital to
allow
certain uh consults to happen when
there's agreement between the primary
team and the specialty team that it's an
appropriate use
a quick visual on this
again this is using the intouch platform
so in the icus and other designated
coveted units there are control stations
at desktops
or you can use an ipad as a control
station and on the patient side
there are ipads that are available for
in-room use
to facilitate communication um
additionally we uh added the intouch
telemedicine cart uh higher end endpoint
into our code blue response um so this
now enters the room
during a resuscitation to again minimize
the number of providers that actually
have to enter the room
and provide good communication in and
out of the room via the ipad control
station with the rest of the care team
to decrease the number of times the door
needed to be opened
and again reducing exposures there
there's more to be said on that but in
the interest time i'm going to zip
through and hand it over to darren
thank you miles and steve uh it's pretty
clear
that a tremendous amount of
effort and work and change management
took place during covid and
i just want to give a shout out to the
work that steve and cork and
others did to get us off the ground with
this massive
expansion of telephone and video visits
and it really a massive team effort
um but i think calling that out early on
was was really crucial to our success so
thank you for that
and i often say that that kobud really
did three years of change management
work for us in three weeks
and when you hear all the background
from miles and steve about where
things stood prior to covered with with
digital health or telehealth
it really was a lot of tools looking for
an indication or looking for adoption
and we had a lot of success with
econsults and miles described those as
one of our
provider-to-provider asynchronous tools
where they get a
basically upscale email consult through
the emr
that has targeted questions and answers
in an asynchronous convenient manner and
now as of
last month it's a billable service for
us and we used to have to say to people
you know they would ask when do we do
these in between the rest of our duties
how many will there be and when do i
squeeze it in and we keep doing getting
uncompensated
efforts here and we said well the future
state
could be if we can just be imaginative
where you have five or ten e consults in
a day plus you scatter in some
video visits and you do some medical
review of referrals
and you could do a half session of
digital work maybe even in your office
or even at home
with a pie in the sky idea and we were
peddling as stevie's though we were
cuddling
this this vision and trying to get
people to come along the way
uh in an iterative fashion by making the
case and generating awareness and desire
and
following change management strategies
and it was moving but it was going
slowly
and then cobig really took away a lot of
the resistance because as steve said it
was very obvious that patients needed to
access us
their ability and desire to change and
try new tools
was present our team's desire to pivot
and do what was needed to reach our
patients was there
and the financial viability with the
relaxing of restrictions and improved
payment
really all lined up so that because we
had the
know-how from early work with urgent
care and others
we were able to pivot off of that and
expand rapidly
so just so many things lined up ideally
to put us in a position for success and
now
our key strategy is to
is to make this sustainable and embed
this within our health systems
mindset and nomenclature and make this
the new
normal and so even on the next five
miles
um this was some work that we actually
did through the ohsu 2025 strategic
planning process
and fortunately a lot of our
leaders and partners within our health
system collaborate with the
crowdsourcing
process that took place uh i guess about
a year and a half ago now
and we already knew that we need to be
more intentional about digital health
we've been dabbling we've been doing
things small scale
but we needed to set some health system
goals and targets
to raise visibility and then be able to
align efforts moving forward
so the office of digital health was
envisioned as a way to do that for all
of
the partners in our health system and
we also knew that there were a lot of
things going on in the background
with consumerism and patient desire and
improved payments gradually happening
for these services
and our goal was to go from starting at
about 8 000 digital visits
a year out of about a million ambulatory
visits
and that includes all of the tools that
miles described earlier in the
ambulatory setting
he consults e-visits video visits
telephone visits
that those we want that to eventually
get to 20
of our ambulatory book of business we
knew that kaiser purported to have
upwards of 40
and that would include my chart
messaging and emailing so we figured 20
would be reasonable and we've seen other
reports that told us that that seemed
reasonable
in five years so our goal for 2020
fiscal year 20 was to get to 1.6 percent
and then double until we got to 20
percent we also wanted to increase
my chart adoption utilization and then
also optimize it to encourage that
means that that's the portal to video
visits as well as the nation you can use
way to interact with patients and
eventually schedule and handle payment
and really gain some efficiencies for
our system
we wanted to improve our user experience
ohsu is
known as being the highest quality but
least accessible
health system in the state how do we
find ways to improve that and improve
our net promoter scores
how do we have online scheduling one of
the biggest things when patients are
surveyed they want out of an app or a
tool is online scheduling
zoom care and open table for restaurants
have told us that and shown us that
patients want control and access and
convenience
we also can use this to promote our
relationship with the state as a
tertiary coordinator center
we'll receive more patient consults and
requests and referrals in a more digital
sense
and then remain competitive in the
marketplace as providence and kaiser
heavily led the way locally
with more digital tools and systemness
and we have the added
challenge of being a new health system
with community partners with
varying amounts of emr integration and
organizational integration
how do we on top of that have some
some systemness around doing this on the
next slide
it shows our digital health steering
committee and so often digital health
exists and reports up through anthony
mashotra with dotted
we really try to have both an inpatient
and ambulatory presence
for the health system and there's the
health it's digital health council one
of many councils that were created
after again which just used 2025
visioning i think we're seeing some of
the gains
of the the alignment that those councils
afford
and the digital steering committee
reports up to that health i.t and
digital health council
that council is co-chaired by bridget
barnes and thief saman so adding in the
itn clinical lens
and then mark lovren and i co-chair the
digital health steering committee
and you can see that representation here
includes adult pediatrics
inpatient ambulatory it's
interdisciplinary uh
dr hirsch provides some leadership for
us and also helped with part of the
strategic planning process last year
and we have a lens for paired strategy
and vulnerable populations with katrina
mcpherson
our health plan services cmo we have
again surgical and medical as well and
have communication
and regulatory team members also
contributing uh there's so much we have
to do to move any of these initiatives
forward
and we're trying to use the term digital
health more instead of telehealth
because it's really more expanded
it's interacting with the patient about
their care with
an electronic tool with asynchronous
care it's less the direct
telecommunication
but digital health is taking on more of
a broad view and that's
why we labeled this the office of
digital health
on the next slide this shows the
organizational structure
and we uh it took us about a year and a
half but eventually with our
financial improvement and our ability to
store salaries we're also able to be
able to include in the fiscal 21 budget
positions to expand the office of
digital health to be able to take on
this really
this this work that now is at a totally
different scale as steve said
we went from 15 plus today to 900 plus a
day
4 000 increase so i did my math
correctly
which is pretty phenomenal
and so what to do that and to maintain
quality
and training and communication and the
payer strategy around all of this
we need a bigger team especially if we
want to continue to add and expand
things that were on our roadmap
and we had a three-year staffing model
to get to this point
and because of our rapid expansion in
terms of volume and being that really
over 30 percent of our ambulatory volume
is now digital
again being point eight percent last
year we obviously more infrastructure to
pull this off
both dedicated team members as well as
those that are embedded within our other
itg
epic support teams on the bottom right
there and
uh we'll now be posting positions and
building the team to really take this
work to the next level
on the next slide it shows our
priorities for moving forward
so with this infrastructure in mind and
some additional resources in place
and growing where do we go from here we
have all those tools
in the sort of ecosystem we want to get
alignment and be strategic about how we
move forward
and so optimizing our current tools is
our key and now that we've reached our
goal of 20
let's not fall below it a lot will be
necessary to maintain that once the
regulations that steve's
uh illustrated for us uh potentially go
away
or some of them stay and some of them
change and whether it's cms and
commercial are different
we need to be able to stay on top of
that which gets down to that strategic
bullet the third one below
if we're going to be able to maintain
those volumes external e consults are
also desired how can providers around
the state
send us low acuity consults and avoid
formal referrals and maintain that care
in the medical home
that's something we have active and
active pilot about to start around
smart exam is a local tool developed by
a company brightmd that some of you are
likely familiar with and those are going
to be labeled urgent care evisits
very highly functional user friendly for
both the patient provider
range for low acuity pre-programmed
templates so to speak that wind up
allowing us to decrease the need for
other types of care we have a new
quality committee
led by miles and amber hoffman and we're
tying into a vision
benchmarking initiative that just
launched and this will likely be the
future state
for for business will not just be
ambulatory and inpatient quality
measures
but likely i would imagine a digital
collaborative and digital quality
measures
that we'll be a part of from the start
which is great a digital care hub online
and within my chart for patients to know
what the tools are and how to make the
right choices
clearly that's needed with all the new
tools and the massive volume we have
and how do we keep a diversity equity
inclusion lens to some of the points
that steve
uh has made and that jonathan sacks has
helped this research and miles has made
points about in the past
including a broadband divide taking
socioeconomic status and race
out of the equation just geography is
also a factor at times
in the hospital world as miles described
expanding the tell icu
drive adoption of the current tools that
have been described for telephone
interprofessional consoles to replace
curbsides
which are undocumented and uncompensated
and really less medical legally safe and
optimal
as well as direct patient video and
telephone visits or consoles
and then developing the virtual icu and
more formal launching of that
in in january with more resources to
make that a reality
and then from a strategic health system
sense this
digital health now is really tied into
payer strategy it's in ambulatory
operations it's an inpatient operations
it's part of finance council
it really touches everything we do now
that we're 30 of ambulatory business
it's a much different conversation
than when we were 0.8 so it's really
relevant in a lot of these venues
and how do we stay connected to that as
well as interstate licensing our pro
board and medical staff office
as these regulations tighten up and
waivers go away
how do we maintain our ability to reach
our patients
in the new world and then how do we
communicate these changes internally and
externally
and have a consumer oriented approach
and
be mindful of what's also going on in
our market because that's really who
we're competing with
patients find an easy smooth seamless
process they will stick with that
organization
so anyways lots of comments in the chat
that we can get to and it'd be great to
just have open discussion and hear your
thoughts and maybe even talk about
research opportunities if that's germane
to the group so thanks a lot for your
time and attention
yeah thanks i want to thank all three of
you that was a great
great talk it's fascinating to hear
everything that's happening and all the
experiences
if if any of you want to um address any
comments in the chat
um that
why don't you just go ahead and do that
yeah i can take on the first
uh comment from faiza i'm sorry if i'm
mispronouncing that
bison um regarding uh not being able
auscultate and so forth
uh yes and i like to always highlight
that
you have to recognize the limitations of
the platform you're on obviously if
you're
on a my chart encounter with a patient
you're going to have different
limitations if you're on the telephone
you're getting a little bit more video
more
and then in person even more it's on the
spectrum of care delivery and you need
to
make sure you recognize those
limitations um
and then the quality of the exam you're
able to do is going to depend on the
camera that the patient has on their end
so when i've been on the high-end video
carts i've been able to do pupillary
exams and there's an electronic
stethoscope and so those type of things
can happen
um and then you can use a telepresence
around the patient and to facilitate
like an abdominal exam
and so forth so there's modifications
that can be made if you can anticipate
that if you're
calling into the home that's obviously
going to be much more limited
there are peripherals that can be used
in the home to
provide more data and we i think will
learn how to
figure out what's safe and comfortable
what can be what limits can be tested
and you know taking a research
evaluation lens is
is important to consider in that regard
and then so christine's comment about
is this a bigger team or can we gain
some efficiencies perhaps by doing
digital care versus in-person care
and how does this right to capacity so
there's a lot of data slides that have
been generated and just to talk about
the last part first
what we found in psychiatry is like the
best example
quickly after coviz they went from uh
one
you know their baseline volume of visits
to 120 percent of their baseline
capacity
by doing a by far a majority of their
visits digitally
they actually many of them now prefer
video visits patients seem more
comfortable
sharing behavioral health topics
information when they're in their home
as opposed to a vulnerable location
which a doctor's office could be or not
is for many and in general we found that
we're about 110 of our baseline
ambulatory volume
now but 70 of that is in person
and 30 is digital so our goal ultimately
to get back to our 100 percent of
ambulatory volume in person that we used
to do
and add 20 digital capacity on top of
that so without having to invest in any
more bricks and mortar structures which
will be
hard to come by and we also may not need
to
uh we can increase capacity and access
and that way you're adding
staff for providers only or maybe making
them more efficient with their time
the other team members involved in
business we are now in part of a
standard work best practice
experiment to figure out if we need mmas
for the same amount of work for digital
versus in person
we might need them more for certain
things versus others but
ideally we would be able to have fewer
team members
per visit basically or per thousand
visits a month
but we need to get to that point um so
the clinic operations teams
may become more efficient in terms of
the infrastructure team within the
office of digital health and our i.t
partners
that team does need to grow to take on
this additional work
there are some uh there's another
comment from fisa
a comment from michael i don't know if
any any of you
i i would just um uh i think it was uh
darren who made the
uh point about the
access to to disparate
populations um one of our informatics
colleagues in
new york city some of the people on the
conference know
jessica anchor who's who said that
broadband internet should really be a
social determinant of health now it's
it's not just something we have at home
we need it for our health we need it for
our children to get to
school and so forth and i thought that
was an interesting
comment yeah so
building on that bill you know one of
the things that we've we've heard from
other organizations in terms of trying
to figure out
you know which vulnerable populations
that use of telemedicine might be
creating challenges for is some of the
systems in new york have actually
extended their network
into the um
into the uh into the shelter
organizations to be able to provide
access there because some people do have
phones but they don't have
you know they don't have the data plans
to support it so they're actually um
providing their network there now so
people can access care
great well um we're just we're just
about at the hour
um and i see that uh
darren answered michael's questions so
um
i i want to thank our speakers it was
very uh
interesting and informative talk and um
maybe in the future sometime we'll we'll
we'll get an update
especially if the world ever reverts to
a semi-normal state
um how all of this will will continue on
so um thanks everyone and we'll um
see you at the conference next week bye
bye
thank you thank you